foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
are you ready for some databases
yep
the Need for Speed so we will have a
really exciting day today on databases
so I am Andy Goodman's general manager
and VP of engineering for Google Cloud
databases and I'm super excited today to
share with you what's new and what's
next for our databases joining me on
stage will be rithika Gunner senior
product management in the database team
Sundar narasiman SVP of saber labs and
product strategy and a fantastic group
of demo presenters there's nothing like
demos so we have plenty of them in
today's session
so it's no surprise to anyone in this
audience that generative AI has really
captured our imagination and it has
opened up new possibilities in all
facets of our daily lives from text and
image generation like you saw in today's
keynote with Thomas to immersive
collaboration tools and even to
augmented search experiences
gen AI is the key to unlocking value in
the Enterprise
and it really has the power to transform
customer experiences and employee
productivity and we're going to talk
about both of those today
we believe we're entering a
post-training era
large language models also refer to as
llms are already democratizing access to
AI for Developers
no longer do developers need to be
experts in deep Trading
but sorry in deep learning but rather
know how to best take advantage of llms
according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics there's 10 times more
developers than data scientists so
imagine if we can put AI into developers
hands we'll have at least an order of
magnitude more Innovation from Ai and so
as a result we believe that application
developers will be driving the bulk of
the innovation in applying generative AI
within the Enterprise
now these developers are going to be
looking for the best ways to leverage
and integrate gen AI into both new and
existing applications
and they're also best positioned to take
advantage of the power of llms with
application data to deliver the best and
most interesting innovation in the
Enterprise
we think about this shift as the shift
to generative engineering or as I like
to call it in short gen engine
just as developers integrated Ops
practices into software development and
we call it devops and and the devops
movement started we already see gen Eng
as the Revolution being led by
developers who have Proficiency in
applying gen AI
and with the rise of gen Edge the real
value for Enterprise comes when
developers are combining generative AI
with their proprietary data to provide
accurate domain-specific experiences
and so because of that and because
operational database sit at the heart of
all application data they really play a
critical role in how developers will
ultimately build these new AI assisted
experiences
now Google Cloud we offer
industry-leading databases for any size
organization this includes a broad set
of innovative databases both relational
and non-relational such as alloy DB
Cloud SQL Cloud spanner firestore
bigtable and more
and we see leading organizations such as
Equifax Deutsche Bank Renault
saber Yahoo and others modernizing their
application stacks and building new
applications with Google Cloud databases
now let's hear from one such customer
character AI about how they're using
alloy dbn spanner to power their
generative AIS
thank you
character AI is a generative AI platform
that allows users to both create
characters with personalities that feels
alive
and engage with these characters in a
way that is almost indistinguishable
from human interaction
millions of users use character for
millions of different use cases gaming
and entertainment book recommendations
recipes and life coaching
the database is the center of any
application
since the migration to lodb we actually
serve five times the query volume at
half the query latency and confidently
provide a reliable service to our users
with very high uptime
spanner is Best in Class distributed
system that is known throughout the
industry to be Rock Solid and allows us
to ingest terabytes of data every day
without any worry that we're going to
bring aside down
goal is to scale one of the fastest
growing consumer products on the market
and that means getting to a billion
users
and with Google Cloud I know we can get
that
[Music]
I just love what character AI you're
doing and thanks so much for your
partnership James
now in order to help organizations like
character AI innovate faster
we're focusing on key three on three key
areas first of all providing operational
databases with built-in gen AI
second breaking down the silos between
transactional and analytical systems
and lastly helping you modernize your
database Estates by migrating off Legacy
proprietary databases
now let me start with Gen AI
today gen AI applications face a variety
of challenges that llms alone do not
solve first they need to provide
accurate and up-to-date information
second you want to deliver contextual
user experiences and last we need to
enable developers to innovate quickly
and make it easy for them to build and
operate their applications
now databases with Vector support are
what we see is the bridge between llms
and Enterprise gen AIS
now here's why first databases generally
can provide the most up-to-date data for
augmenting llm prompts
and this helps this helps us ground llms
for accuracy and relevance
and combine it by combining data from
your production databases with the Parov
llms your gen AI apps will provide
accurate answers based on real-time data
second much of this data especially
conversational data is unstructured
and Vector embeddings can encode the
semantic meaning of this unstructured
data like product descriptions help desk
tickets and conversation history
this allows your applications to bring
relevant unstructured data from your
database to the llm based experience
enabling immersive semantic search and
complex history-based conversations
and lastly the best part is you can do
it within your database right the
database that you trust and love and and
they're already supported by robust
ecosystem with the business critical
reliability data protection and
performance you expect
and developers already so familiar with
them they don't have to learn or set up
new systems
now postgres has emerged as the
industry-leading relational database
because of its Rich functionality
ecosystem and thriving community and
according to stack Overflow it is the
most popular database in use today by
professional developers with over half
of them choosing postgres
and we're seeing a lot of innovation in
the postgres community around Vector
search
such as extensions like PG vector so
these are really really exciting times
to be part of the postgres community and
the combination of vector search and SQL
really enables these very expressive
powerful design patterns while remaining
simple and familiar
now we already support the best postgres
compatible database with loadb
and ADB runs anywhere it runs in the
cloud it runs on premises it runs at the
edge
but we wanted to do more
and so we asked our customers what they
needed as part of their gen AI
application development Journey
and here's what we heard
first it's got to be easy and integrated
second it needs to run everywhere
and then lastly it needs to perform well
because our customers are building very
interactive experiences
so we went off and we innovated
and as you heard in Thomas's keynote
today we announced alloy dbai
atodb AI provides PG Vector compatible
search that is up to 10 times faster
than standard postgres so you can really
get those interactive experiences using
adodb AI it also allows you to generate
Vector embeddings directly from within
your database and fully integrates with
vertex Ai and the open source gen AI
ecosystem
and as an integral part of value DB
alloy dbai runs everywhere so not just
in Google pretty much anywhere you want
it to run now let's double click on some
of these key features within lodb AI
first our PG Vector compatible search
was tightly integrated into the alloy DB
query processing engine which gives us
up to 10 times better performance as I
mentioned
in addition we've added Vector
quantization support so we can actually
support vectors that are four times
larger than standard postgres
second alloy DB automates embeddings
generation to easily transform that
unstructured operational data into
Vector embeddings simplifying your gen
AI app development that includes
automatically generating embeddings
using remote models in vertex AI
and we've even brought in some
lightweight models into alloy dbai so
for some lightweight use cases you can
actually generate those embeddings
within the database itself and that
simplifies the stack significantly
improves latencies and dramatically
reduces cost
and lastly
alodb AI fully integrates a Vertex Ai
and open source tools such as Lang chain
to best support Developers
so in summary allo DB now provides
everything you need really the key
capabilities you need to build and run
Enterprise gen AI apps and we're going
to continue to innovate on rwb AI as
quickly as we can based on your feedback
it is available in preview today through
the downloadable ADB Omni that runs
everywhere and soon will be launched on
the Adobe managed service
now let's take a look at iwbai in action
with sandy guy
thanks Andy let's explore how easy it is
to build a gen AI enabled experience
using this functionality and just to
show you guys how open this platform is
and how easy it is to take advantage of
wherever you are I'm actually going to
demo this on AWS with alloy DB Omni
we're building an app for simple
Superstore a home improvement store with
locations across the country
today we have a simple application built
on our database but we'd like to build a
more interactive experience where
customers are bring us the problems
they're looking to solve
just like they do in person when they
interact with our friendly helpful
Associates
so we decided to incorporate an llm to
power a chat application
let's consider a simple use case a
customer enters the Redwood City store
and asks the question what kind of fruit
tree would grow well in my backyard
this is the response of an llm without
any additional context
that's great except we don't have any
apple or fig trees in stock
so let's make this better by grounding
the llm in our own operational data
let's take a look at our alloy DB
instance in my SQL notebook
now we've already migrated our data into
alloy DB Omni so my product catalog and
inventory data is already here
with a single line of SQL
I can add a column that will
automatically generate Vector embeddings
from my product descriptions
this simple postgres function
calls a remote model in vertex AI text
embeddings gecko
to transform my data into embeddings
I could also use a local model that runs
on the database itself with no need for
specialized Hardware
now in the interest of time I've already
computed embeddings on thirty thousand
rows for each product in my product
catalog and created an index
so how do we use these embeddings to
make our llm more actionable
first I construct our prompt in
generative AI Studio
as you can see here my prompt provides
guidance for the llm on the user and how
to answer the question
as part of the prompt I want to feed the
llm a list of candidate products to draw
from
in a perfect world I'd feed the llm all
of my in-stock products but that exceeds
our llm token limits instead let's try
to feed the llm 10 highly relevant
candidate products
so jumping back to my notebook
I have my products table
and as you can see I have my new product
embeddings column there
and I have my inventory table
great
so to construct my query I need to join
these two tables filter for in-stock
items in the Redwood City store and then
sort based on similarity to the user's
query string using PG Vector let's run
this query
that was pretty fast as Andy mentioned
alloy DB runs Vector queries 10x faster
than standard postgres
okay so now I found 10 Canada products
it looks pretty good
okay so now let's feed all of this to
the llm including the user's input and
the candidate products
I'm going to convert these to Json
and then go back to my generative AI
Studio prompt and paste them in here
remember the user's question was what
kind of fruit tree would grow well in my
backyard
amazing I have results
let's see
a Meyer lemon tree
that's in stock I love that because it's
not only a great recommendation for this
user but they can walk out of the store
with it today
because I asked the llm to return the
product ID as part of its response I can
validate the response and provide the
user with more information like photos
and location in the store
this is what the end user experience
looks like to the customer
and if I follow up with something like
what do I need to do for it to grow well
here we can follow the same process
generate a list of candid products based
on the question and previous llm
interactions
feed that to the llm and have it use the
products to generate a recommendation
as you can see the key to making this
feel rich
personalized actionable and Enterprise
grade It's a combination of your data
with llms
an allo dbai makes that super easy no
extra mail stack no moving data around
no convoluted application architecture
just a few lines of SQL
thanks and now I'm passing this back to
Andy thank you
[Applause]
so two things I love about that Demo
First it just shows you how easy it is
to kind of bring Vector search into your
SQL and of course the second one it ran
on AWS there was a live demo on AWS and
it really shows you that you can
actually use alloy DB Omni everywhere
now Switching gears as you heard in the
opening keynote duet AI in Google Cloud
isn't always on collaborator that uses
generative AI to help Cloud users of all
types do accomplish what they need to
accomplish better and faster for example
developers are often challenged in
writing and optimizing complex database
queries so we decided to help them
today we're excited to announce the
preview of duetei in Cloud spanner
with duet Ai and Cloud spanner you can
generate code to structure modify or
query your data using natural language
with the red Ai and Cloud spanner it
will automatically generate SQL that can
be reviewed or Modified by developers so
they can spend more time innovating and
less time writing and optimizing their
SQL code
now let's look at the power of duet Aion
Cloud spanner with cat Coleman
let's say I'm working at a fictitious
gaming company symbol games
lately we've been having a problem with
player churn and I've been asked to dive
in and help identify a list of players
that we think are at risk of leaving our
game
here's how I can use duet AI to quickly
and seamlessly complete this using
natural language prompts
to start I navigate to the new spanner
studio in the cloud console where I can
structure modify and query my game's
data
I want to see the number of active
players in the last 30 days to see how
we're trending in natural language is
duet AI how to query this data
duet AI automatically suggests SQL code
that I can then explore and modify
I see the numbers are a little lower
than usual
I can use a machine learning model to
predict which players are at risk of
churn right now
great duet AI Returns the number of
at-risk players we have right now to
prevent these players from churning I'm
going to give them some player
appreciation tokens with a little more
help from duet AI
and voila
using duet AI in Cloud spanner I was
able to Breeze through a sophisticated
task using natural language prompts all
inside of the new spanner Studio
so this is super powerful as you can see
you may have also heard we announced
something very similar on bigquery today
as you're going to have this kind of
experience also in bigquery and rest
assured I know the next question is
going to be like when does it come to
Cloud SQL when does it come to halodb we
definitely have an intention
to also bring these kind of capabilities
to our other database services
now as you saw in Thomas's keynote today
duet AI will also simplify the last mile
of complex database migrations from
Oracle to postgres and we will cover
that later on in this session so we can
tell you how duet AI is actually going
to help accelerate that now I'm going to
hand it over to rithika to talk about
how we're unifying transactional and
analytical systems
[Applause]
foreign
doing some great database announcements
and we're going to keep the drum beat
going so data has always been a critical
ingredient for the successful
application of AI and that's why our
second Focus area is around unifying our
data in AI Cloud by breaking down the
barriers between transactional and
analytical systems to deliver the
freshest and most contextually relevant
data to apps and to decision making so
one example of this is data stream for
bigquery which provides a simple and
easy real-time data replication from
transactional databases like alloy DB
postgres MySQL and Oracle directly into
bigquery today data stream for bigquery
serves thousands of customers and
processes over half a trillion events
every single month now we've also
delivered query Federation capabilities
with Cloud spanner Cloud SQL and
bigtable May taking data available right
from the bigquery console allowing you
to analyze your transactional data in
real time
but we wanted to build on these
capabilities and provide a truly
Innovative way to democratize
operational data for analytical purposes
and that's why today we're announcing
the general availability of cloud
spanner data boost
this is a breakthrough technology
delivering high performance workload
isolated on-demand processing of
operational data to support analytics
reporting and more data boost takes
advantage of Google's disaggregated
compute and storage architecture and
provides on-demand isolated compute
resources to process analytical queries
directly on the storage layer with
virtually no impact to the existing
transactional workload with data boost
users can analyze their Cloud spanner
data via bigquery VIA spark on dataproc
they can export it using dataflow or
they can use it in their own custom
applications
and because these resources are fully
managed by Google with a pay-per-use
model it provides a cost-effective
secure and scalable architecture without
any additional management overhead
Cloud spanner data boost is Federation
done right
now let's take a look at data boosts in
action I'd like to welcome my colleague
Gabe Weiss to the stage to give us a
live demo to show us the power of data
boost welcome Gabe
hi everyone I've been given the
impossible task of demonstrating awesome
database performance live on stage
which you're totally not seeing me do
right now is kicking off
theoretically kicking off a couple of
queries both because I need you to see
me doing it live so I can prove to you
that there is no tricks no magic nothing
at my sleeves and because I need to be
able to show you the impact or in this
case no impact because data boost is
awesome that these operations are going
to have on our database the spanner
instance we're using is emulating a
database for a massively multiplayer
online role-playing game this particular
instance is tracking all of our player
activity around their inventory and
in-game currency it's currently sitting
at just over three terabytes of data and
the table that we'll be interacting with
has over 4 billion rows
in our game the monetization folks
monitor the player activity in near real
time so they can adjust offers on the
fly during Live Events and do deeper
analytics for future events these folks
want to constantly analyze live player
activity that lives in spanner combined
with the historical data and analytics
living in bigquery all this has to
happen without impacting our
transactional workload because what
happens if our inventory system lags in
game
our players are going to figure out how
to exploit it they'll duplicate their
items ruin our in-game economy now I've
got a big problem
so before I dive into about horrible I
mean interesting things that our
analysts are trying to do to our data I
want you to take note of the database
name so I can prove to you that all this
is happening against the same spanner
database game DB we have two external
connections from bigquery they're both
against game DB the only difference is
that one is not using data boost and one
is using data boost okay next I want to
show you our CPU utilization graph we've
taken the game servers offline so that I
can really show you what's happening and
right about now you might be saying to
yourself hey Gabe wait a second I
totally see CPU spikes on that graph I
thought you said data boost was supposed
to prevent that from happening and
you're right it does
let's take a look at the time stamp here
so 402
if you're keeping track of time I wasn't
even on stage yet so let me show you
this is the window where uh I ran the
query before I came on stage look at the
creation time
401 lines up with our CPU Spike so this
is the query that ruined our economy the
query analyzes the players that have
been dealing in the highest value items
across the last 75 days so we know who
to Target with our in-game ads now here
is the window that I ran at the
beginning of our our demo it's the same
SQL query but I want you to take note
our connection string this one ran with
data boost enabled and if you remember
at the beginning I kicked off a couple
of queries because one query just wasn't
dangerous enough for me
so this is a notebook that runs a spark
job that calculates the rolling
retention of our entire player base in
other words give me a list of all the
players that have traded at least one
item in a specified week or any week
they're after it's a very intense
calculation that ends up scanning most
of our 4 billion rows and if you note in
the notebook here we have again same
database data boost enabled true
all right is everyone ready to see some
magic
back to our CPU graph I'm going to go
ahead and refresh it on the last hour
all right here we have our PR nightmare
inducing CPU Spike caused by the no data
boost connection and here is the
timestamp at the beginning of this demo
I'd like you to note there is no Spike
so data boost has successfully isolated
our analysts queries and avoided ruining
our in-game economy everything you saw
here today is detailed in a blog post so
that you can recreate this in your
environment please don't take my word
for it we've got more Demos in the
Showcase area of the Expo floor and at
the innovators Hive come on by and chat
thanks back to eurydica
foreign
wasn't that a fantastic demo showing you
the power of data boost well this is why
customers such as Cirque a Brazilian
financial institution are quickly
adopting data boost to benefit from
real-time analytics on spanner data now
to further break down the silos between
transactional and analytical data we're
also making it easier to ingest data
from bigquery back to operational
databases like bigtable with just a few
clicks applications often need data from
their data warehouse for use cases such
as personalization or recommendations
however typically getting such data into
operational databases means filing very
laborious ETL jobs or filing help
tickets from your data Engineers but we
think there's a better way to where a
developer can get the data directly into
their data warehouse into directly from
their data warehouse into their
operational databases use using
self-service native ETL capabilities
today we're excited to announce reverse
ETL support from bigquery into bigtable
with the new bigquery export to bigtable
feature applications can serve and
analytical insights to their users
without having to touch any ETL tools
this feature is available for sign up
and preview
now these are some of the ways we're
bringing truly differentiated
capabilities to unify our data and AI
workloads across the entire data life
cycle but don't take my word for it One
customer who's built a data and AI
Foundation across Google's data and AI
cloud is saber saber is a software
technology company that powers the
Global Travel industry processing more
than 12 billion shopping requests across
1 billion Travelers every year let's
welcome to the stage SVP president of
saber labs and product strategy Sundar
narasiman to talk about how they're
partnering with Google to transform
their business Sunder welcome
hello everyone
how are you doing
it's kind of afternoon isn't it
my name is sunder narsim and I also lead
Enterprise architecture and platform
engineering at saber
and today from a customer Viewpoint I
thought I'd share with you our journey
to Google Cloud tell you a little bit
about what saber does
how we've approached the process of
migration and then spend a little bit
time talking about databases in
particular and leave you with a few
thoughts about what I think the future
might look like I've been really excited
to hear rithika Andy and others showcase
some of the really cool
I'd say Innovations in the in this space
and over the next few minutes we'll
cover a few of those
so what is saber and probably not many
of you know us
we are a
company that we aspire to be a global
Premier Technology platform in travel
and if you we operate in two sort of
business units
Airline Solutions as part of travel
Solutions we really run
what are called passenger service
systems that provide retailing
distribution and fulfillment for some of
the world's largest Airlines you may
recognize American Airlines JetBlue
Alaska and even other countries other
airlines across the globe let that and
go Etc
we also run a travel Marketplace we take
those Airlines and we connect the
content that they provide to sellers
across the globe and we do the same sort
of thing for hotel years and that's
really what the hospitality Solutions
business unit is and in the marketplace
that we sell we have 400 Airlines maybe
a million plus hotels
and
about 50 000 odd agencies some of them
are online
Priceline you may have heard of e-travel
group but also that's not only Leisure
Travelers but business Travelers you may
have heard of Amex gbt cwt so in short
we really sit at the middle of travel
transactions there were B2B company
predominantly been business for several
decades
and when we thought about what it would
take to take this company which had you
know a plethora of Technologies running
from mainframes mid-ranges we really
started with thinking through not just
migrating to the cloud and learning to
operate in fact the people enable them
inside of it really we have one of the
largest trained workforces in Google
Cloud but we really said that wasn't
enough we needed to transform the
company the way we operate the way we
think about developing solutions for our
customers for end users for travelers
and
saber for all of our existence has been
one about Innovation and we said not
only do we need to migrate put our
Platforms in the cloud but they need to
facilitate the innovations that
Travelers need and we all want to expect
from a platform company such as saber
and databases are at the core of all of
this
and if we cart back into you know many
of you are Enterprise companies that if
you ask looking and if you've been in
the business for a couple of decades
saber was you had pretty much one of
everything
in operational databases we had
mainframes we had large
Oracle everywhere and we also had
document databases couch base and
object-oriented databases vertica on the
analytical side again we had
pretty much teradata vertica we had ran
our own Hadoop clusters
and when we thought about where we
wanted to go it wasn't just about
migrating every one of those into
Google Cloud but as ritika said what was
actually happening in the database
industry is this unification that she
talked about the unification of
transactional data with what you might
call analytical data because if you look
at the trends of storage compute these
we realize we're going to converge and
in order to create that Innovative new
applications that our customers wanted
it was about imbuing embedding travel AI
in all of our applications We examined
all of our suite and we identified over
60 such use cases where travel AI those
little what I call raisins in the loaf
of bread that would really enhance our
product offering to our customers and
not only are we going to embed this AI
application in this call it integrated
data
ecosystem but we also needed to connect
end-to-end applications that all of our
use cases up over the top that you see
in effect taking advantage of the new AI
capabilities that would enable them to
make even more money make enhance user
experiences possible for all of us as
Travelers
and if you looked at what's different
about saber compared to maybe you know
other database users or companies most
of our databases are Enterprise class
have lots of pii PCI if you're all
probably typed your passport in
international travel
PCI Data obviously we pay with credit
cards and gdpr privacy is very important
and so the security and compliance
requirements of these databases are
immense
and the consistency requirements have
been in place since the 60s and 70s when
some of these databases were put in
place in fact the early days of saber
advertisements literally had pictures of
people with people sitting on the same
seat like multiple people on the same
seat because until saber came along
even seat assignments were not done in a
consistent way
and if you look at availability
in we say how many nines right five four
six in fact we have SLA penalties if we
drop or have outages not only do we get
written in the paper we make all of you
traveling public suffer we want to get
home
and or to an important business meeting
so these kind of requirements are really
what you know we live by we breathe and
we think about and in terms of how we
ended up you know using these plethora
of database products that you heard Andy
and others talk about
the key point I would like to leave with
you is really think about the contextual
use cases
when you have strong transactional
consistency requirements
without compromising on scalability or
performance spanner is a great choice
and in fact the PNR those six character
locators that you
kind of see in your itinerary
confirmations right those are called
passenger Name Records and that complex
is perhaps one of the most demanding in
terms of performance and when we lifted
it and made it run on spanner it wasn't
easy right
it was in effect required while we
satisfied the acid requirements we
connected it using Pub sub to other
multiple Regional spanner replicas that
were optimized for read performance so
I'd encourage you to think about that
kind of uh what might call use cases
where spanner really shines
on the bottom you know there are the use
cases not all of you know if you want to
be cost effective there are other use
cases we sell products and I've listed a
couple of them there where we provide
Market intelligence or Global demand
data to our customers and for those uh
kind of use cases
the other databases that you know such
as alloy DB or Cloud SQL are perfect
matches
and last but not the least at the very
top
we as I mentioned we had a lot of Oracle
databases and in order to realize our
shutdown of our on-prem data centers in
a timely fashion we literally move them
to essentially the bare metal Solution
on Oracle and we still continue to run
some of them but in the process of
migrating as Andy you know kind of
previewed our databases and
consolidating them in an integrated form
that we actually hope to go forward with
in the future
and if you were to say like okay where
are you there you know saber in our
migration Journey we're about a third of
our 10-year Journey
and we would say about 90 percent of our
workloads are in the public cloud and
it's been a great partnership with Andy
and his team they literally sit team by
you know with our Engineers work very
closely with their Engineers to get us
to where we are
and in terms of the future what really
excites us is really all the things you
heard about today in terms of generative
Ai and AI in general that vertex AI
product on which our travel AI products
are built is going to be I think a key
for us as a business going forward and
in fact one of the engineers we had a
hackathon just three weeks ago he said
if you're not using llms every day as a
programmer you're falling behind and not
only is it important to get the
productivity improvements but in terms
of Automation in terms of reducing costs
that in call center applications or help
desk applications all of those are going
to be very important with this
generative Ai and llm Technology
and the second part is also important
this unification that you know ritika
talked about in terms of transactional
and analytical databases I'd go one step
further and say operational data in fact
in the keynote you saw a demonstration
of an alert
triggering a processing step together
all the way through analytical to even
operational data and those kinds of use
cases are real value to not only our B2B
customers they make the lives of end
Travelers be much more you know
enjoyable because at the end of the day
travel is really about you know
connecting to the people in places you
love and that's the mission that we all
see as you know Primary in our business
in in saber and last but not the least
you know we often talk about data as
silos within our own company
and I think it's important that as these
convergences happen companies find new
ways of collaborating across each other
we didn't talk too much about products
like analytics Hub which enable our
partners coalitions those Airlines and
hotels to come together and provide new
products new ways of exploring new ways
of really buying and you know
experiencing travel that isn't possible
today
so with that you know I'd leave you you
know tomorrow there's actually a another
session with Joe defonzo our CIO who's
going to talk about more migrations if
you're interested in it I encourage you
to go to that session I wouldn't but
that I hand it back to rithika
Sunder thank you that was such a great
transformational story I it's been a
pleasure working with Sundar and his
team and the entire saber team on their
data and AI transformation so let's move
to our third theme for Innovation which
is centered on assisting you in
developing modern and data-driven
applications with an emphasis on being
open now open means enabling you to
build your Solutions wherever you need
whether that be on-premises whether that
be across various public clouds or at
the edge it also means making managed
database services available with Open
Standards and open apis while supporting
your mission critical workloads
and lastly it means fostering an open
partner ecosystem of solutions designed
to help you move faster now we've heard
from many of you asking us to help you
modernize your database workloads as
quickly and as easily as possible and we
answered that call with alloy DB you
heard Andy and Sundar talk about the
benefits of alloy DB including the newly
added gen AI Innovations with alloy DB
AI we're thrilled to announce that today
alloy DB Omni the downloadable edition
of alloyed EB is moving from technology
preview into public preview alwdb Omni
is designed to run everywhere on Google
Cloud on AWS Azure on premises and even
on your laptop
since its initial launch we've added
many new features to loydb Omni we've
added many of the Gen AI capabilities
including allo dbai that Andy discussed
earlier we've also Incorporated
additional performance benefits and we
had added support for postgres 15.
we've also added extra utilities to
simplify the management of alloy DB Omni
we're also announcing support for ledb
Omni is another choice in our database
service for Google Cloud distributed
hosted which is our air gapped private
Cloud environment for regulated
customers alliedbi Omni meets you where
you are and can take you where you need
to go in your database modernization
Journey
and we've made it easier than ever to
migrate from these Legacy from Legacy
databases today we're also excited to
announce the general availability of
Oracle to postgres migration to support
our database in our database migration
service we're making it fast and easy to
help Enterprises migrate their schema
their data their PL SQL code from Oracle
to postgres and it doesn't stop there
we're also excited to bring the power of
duet AI to Oracle to postgres migrations
and including alloy DB which is now
available for sign up in preview
with duet Ai and DMS we'll offer AI
assisted code conversion to automate the
conversion of database code such as
stored procedures functions triggers
packages custom PL SQL code all of this
to postgres so let's take a moment to
see it in action
now we're going to start by seeing the
magic you're going to start you saw the
magic of duet AI this morning in the
keynote I pre-recorded a demo here and
let's see in more detail how easy it is
to migrate your Oracle databases to
alloy DB I'll start here by opening up
the console this is your One-Stop shop
to create and manage all of my database
migrations
first I'll open up the conversion
workspace I pre-created I've already
selected the Oracle schema I'd like to
convert on the left you can see that DMS
doesn't just convert the schema objects
like tables and Views but also the
stored procedures and functions I'll
click convert and DMS starts converting
the schema after the initial conversion
it looks like there's still some issues
in the past these would have to be
manually updated which would be both
time consuming and error prone but now
with the power of duet AI I can automate
these and address these last mile
conversions let's see it in action here
you can now see the Oracle tree that
includes all the objects I selected in
the previous step I can now view the
alloy DB postgres tree also which shows
me how DMS converted the source for each
object there's a side-by-side comparison
that you see here that shows the
corresponding Oracle and postgres
dialect you can see here these are the
items that didn't convert see the errors
and warnings normally I'd have to fix
these manually thanks to the power of
duet AI I only have to show the system
how to address a few let's try it out in
this conversion we have a specific
problem because assist state is an
oracle-specific function which depending
on the context doesn't have a postgres
equivalent therefore the translation
requires a manual intervention as soon
as I manually fix the issue duet AI over
here kicks in check it out duet AI has
learned enough to propose a fix for the
remaining objects in this screen I can
navigate through the various suggestions
and review the proposed conversions I
can accept reject or modify the
suggestions we're going to accept all
the suggestions here
now with no outstanding issues I'm now
ready to move the converted schema to
alloy DB now with the biggest and most
complex steps out of the way I can
quickly and easily migrate my jobs and
I'm well underway
now wasn't that amazing
it's no wonder that customers
look it's no wonder that customers like
Chicago Mercantile Exchange group are
looking to alloy DB for their most
demanding workloads and they're already
in the process of migrating several
Oracle databases now being open also
means being committed to delivering the
best open source compatible managed
services so that you can spend more time
innovating and less time on managing the
plumbing of your databases we're
dedicated to making Google Cloud be the
best place to run your MySQL and your
redis workloads Cloud SQL which is our
fully managed relational database
service for MySQL postgres and SQL
Server workloads is used by more than 95
percent of the top 100 Google Cloud
customers last month we announced major
new availability performance and data
protection enhancements in Cloud SQL
with the introduction of Enterprise Plus
Edition for MySQL and postgres workloads
we worked closely with customers and the
result speak for themselves Cloud SQL
Enterprise Plus deliver for MySQL
delivers up to three times higher read
throughput and up to two times
Improvement in write latency compared to
the Enterprise Edition it also delivers
three times higher performance than
Amazon's comparable MySQL service
now in addition to boosting our MySQL
performance with Enterprise Plus we've
also worked on supercharging our memory
store for redis offering with a brand
new capability today we're announcing
the preview of our new fully managed
offering memory store for redis cluster
memory store for redis cluster is an
easy to use open source compatible redis
cluster service that runs on redis 7 and
provides sub millisecond latency with
get this 60 times more throughput than
the existing offering
customers such as Palo Alto networks
tested memory store for redis cluster
and found it to be easy to use highly
performant and easily scalable this is
just another example of how we're making
open source compatible database Services
highly performant while simplifying the
management experience
and finally open just doesn't doesn't
just apply to our technology it's also
about developing an open ecosystem of
Partners today over 1 000 Partners power
their applications using Google's data
and AI cloud and to reinforce our
commitment to Partners we're excited to
launch our new Google cloud ready for
cloud SQL program this is a program that
recognizes partner solutions that have
met the integration requirements with
Cloud SQL and it joins our already
existing Google cloud ready for Alloy DB
partner program
our Google Cloud databases are committed
to helping you build modern data-driven
Enterprise applications with an emphasis
on being open and now to close I'd like
to welcome back Andy
thank you ritika
as you can see from all we've spoken
about today the future of data and AI
has Endless Possibilities Google Cloud
databases offer an intelligent unified
and open platform to support your gen AI
journey and we hope you found today's
session insightful and inspiring here
are three things you can do to learn
more about these Innovations first we
have lots of Deep dive sessions in the
database professionals track
second
showcase on the show floor
and just talk to us Google Cloud experts
we'll be happy to answer your questions
now here's a quick overview of what's
new at next and a list of other valuable
learning experiences
thank you so much for joining us today
enjoy the rest of next